Why is this transformation a good idea?
We still have to share the information
for a source object up here across all these threads.
That doesn't change from our previous implementation.
But now we don't have to share any destination object information at all,
because 1 thread is completely responsible for 1 destination object,
so we can load that object's information directly into that thread's local storage.
And we don't have to communicate between threads to sum up individual forces.
So it used to be we had P different threads here,
and we had to communicate between those P threads to add up all these forces.
Now because we only have 1 thread that's responsible for all these forces,
we don't have to do any communication between threads at all.
That thread can just accumulate all of the partial results in its local storage.
So the result is a faster implementation overall.
Dave discussed this technique generically in the last unit, Unit 5, and he used the term privatization.
So in making this transformation,
is the amount of parallelism now increased, decreased, or kept constant from the previous implementation?